two words
Donald Trump I think of bacon when I
hear American the first thing that comes
to mind when I think of the white
American is Obama division when I hear
the word American i think not Obama
that's a tough question the one word I
think of when I hear the word American
is freedom freedom riddim diverse I kind
of think of immigration just like
America was founded on people like
coming here and migrating it's like 10
about opportunities when I hear the more
America I think a confederate flag the
one word I think of when I hear American
is God God created me he created all of
us and I feel that this is my purpose
was to be an American otherwise I would
have been born any other country and the
other ethnicity
emigrant Mexican